I always wondered you've done so much
for your city I feel like when people
think of your city you're synonymous
with it at this point you're a community
leader at this point did you ever get
unbanned from the Box in Houston so it's
crazy you say in Houston bro I've been
banned I was never just banned in
Houston it was radio one yeah worldwide
still that way so radio one the company
there's still the trade the truth ban
yeah mhm wow but bro was there ever any
has there been any sort I mean look that
was like what over 10 years ago right
like that was so long ago it might have
been longer than that 14 years yeah it's
been so long like you would think people
grow people I I definitely grown I mean
I I haven't thought about them I don't I
don't I don't speak on them I don't I
just keep it moving you know I fought my
lane and it works yeah you know you're
also not an artist that necessarily
needs radio to be successful like right
you know and that's another reason when
I take time to salute a lot of the the
the Young Artists coming up they created
ways where radio isn't necessarily even
needed anymore for you to to chart or
for you to tour for you to monetize you
know what I'm saying support your family
right right so I've definitely it's a
blessing I've I've seen a lot of people
come and go and I'm still here and then
when you think when I actually did have
radio I would nowhere near as big as I
am now
that's some real [__] that's some real
[__] yeah that's true yo when you do you
ever look back at like I you know I was
I was um just talking with uh my boy
Amir about kind of like the peak Grand
Hustle days MH shout out to Dro and and
uh obviously yourself and Bo was in the
mix and Iggy iselia was in the mix
Travis everybody Travis was in the mix
it was just such a crazy like RP um R
you know Tokyo it's it's a lot of us in
there just a crazy
movement I mean before he got you know
aired out I mean I love the alpha mea
dude he had such a crazy voice but do
you ever look back at those days and
just like be like damn like that was
like a moment you know it feels like
sometimes we live and we're a part of
history but we don't know that we're
living in it at the time right and you
it probably actually if you was actually
in it you still would never see it the
way that the outside see like the way
the world saw it right like for instance
me right past the music
like when I come around whether it be
the music or just for me being on front
line of helping people people be amazed
to me I'm normal as can be it's just the
normal me so I don't I don't really
realize what I am to people you know
what I'm saying and even when you speak
of the hustle game when it was you had
everybody talking about hustling
everybody wearing Hustle Gang clothes
Hustle Gang everything you know what I'm
saying to where
I think because we were living in it
it's kind of hard to see what everybody
else saw but we definitely appreciate it
because [__] you know that that was at
that time that everything people was
doing was Hustle Gang you know for sure
for sure I think back like the was it
the BET Awards when like drama was DJing
and just everybody it was just a moment
for sure man a moment in that's what I
was I was also talking about with drama
I was like bro how crazy was that yeah
yeah yeah shout out to them you know
they working on the PSC album right now
really pimp squad click yeah they they
back um I just left from out there me
and T just shot the video to the record
s I'm and I was out there for his movie
premiere make sure everybody go check
out the movie departments um that's
something dope with a bunch of comedians
I going say I love to see TI like pivot
and try to just do whatever like he's
just doing what he wants at this point
like if you're a legend you can just do
what you want and's I don't even think
it's that we do we want the thing it we
just enjoying life that's what I was
going to say like to me he's doing the
the comedy [__] the right way like he's
like going to open mics he's getting on
the mic he's he's he's you know it I
feel like comedy and Hip-Hop there's
parallels like you got to start
somewhere you know what I'm saying and I
feel like he's doing it the right way
yeah his that movie um the movie came
out the P this like what was the movie
with a bunch of comedians back in the
day was that car wash there was a lot of
those movies car saying with a bunch of
big comedians just I don't know about
car wash I remember the wash with Snoop
and Dr Dre neither y was somebody even
way back then with Richard Pride type
yeah I was born in ' 87 so
uh but yeah so yeah it's it's definitely
one of the ones that's going to count um
a bunch of and that yeah and and it's
dope um even though it's son King in
there too but um I think we at a point
life man we just like that's the reason
why I did this album man we just living
like what's the point of waking up angry
every day or or stress or running into
the same walls man we just got to live
and enjoy life like my movie movie
coming out it's a comedy too oh you got
a movie coming yeah it Dr it should drop
any day on tuby it's called Soul um
how's the tuby game cuz I've I swear to
God my favorite thing to do is just
search up tuby on Twitter and just watch
Clips so you know it's two part look
it's two parts of it right you do have
the bootleg movies but they're great
though yeah but some of that [__] be
just funny I can it's hilarious I I I I
was telling him I was like bro we got
the cameras like we should shoot like a
white trash tuby movie definitely would
it definitely would go but the other
thing people don't realize [__] to be be
having better movies than Netflix and
other [__] they be having real no they
have like official sh yeah a lot of
official you know what I'm saying yeah
so that's the thing people should
definitely go cuz you know the first
thing they do is like what you did they
go look at it they like man I'm never
downloading Tu well people who don't
know Tu is free so if you have a smart
TV you're just in the game yeah and then
you know I have Partners like um murder
pain you know Chris and a lot of them
um I believe t- Muller a lot of them you
know they took Tob to another level cuz
we didn't get familiar with tub till we
start watching the show MCG or 211 or
um uh uh what was the other one love um
I know it's it's a lot of them they got
right now yeah tu's uh to be special oh
plug love yeah and I I heard that like
they're really good like like they pay
well if yeah yeah you can they I learned
about tuby they say it was a man who
shot a whole video on the iPhone oh I've
seen ran it up I bet I say ran up a bag
ran it
up what are we doing shooting a movie
come on